Let’s begin to answer this question, “What is motion?”
Well, let’s say motion is changing position.
If something’s position or location is staying the same, well, it’s not moving.
So, position is an important concept, important enough to be written in red.
Actually, it’s not just position that’s important, it is this idea of changing position
which actually leads us to the next concept, velocity or speed,
which measures how quickly an object’s position changes over time.
So, for example, let’s say we have two objects, A and B, and this one’s position changes
from here to here and object B’s position changes from here to here.
I want to know which object move faster.
Was it object A, object B, or can we not tell from the information I’ve given you?
Think about this one, it may not be as obvious as it seems at first.